shut down by saturday with the death
toll from covid 19
nearing 100 000 french president
emmanuel macron
was forced to act we will lose control
if we do not move
now macron has tried to keep the country
open
as a way to protect the already battered
economy
but with many intensive care units at
breaking point
and a slower than planned vaccine
rollout the economy had to wait
remember this figure 44 of patients in
intensive care are today less than
65 years old for the next four weeks
schools and nurseries will be closed
along with non-essential businesses
a curfew will be in place and travel
will be restricted to 10 kilometers from
home
earlier this week macron said regional
lockdowns like in paris
would be enough scientists disagreed
saying partial lockdowns won't stop such
a fast spreading virus
we must prevent the virus from spreading
we can't do it with half measures
these 50 shades of measures for now are
not producing results
and in two weeks we still won't see any
result
so we must go back to a lockdown and
unfortunately
this lockdown will last for several
weeks
then on wednesday macron changed his
tune
for the coming months each one of us
must make an extra effort
this is what i ask of us collectively
this evening
the surge of covid19 cases in france is
linked to the slow rollout of vaccines
across the european union
along with disputed fears surrounding
the astrazeneca vaccine
in the coming weeks we'll accelerate
further the number of doses that we will
obtain
and we will gradually become the first
continent in the world
in terms of vaccine production but for
now
months after the first vaccines were
approved only 12 percent
of the french population is inoculated
leah harding al jazeera